we said before we had an observer right
and the observer is watching something
that's rotating around let's call them
the move off okay so it's like someone
starts here and then they're moving in a
circular motion around so I guess this
is kind of like the Stars right I know
the stars aren't really moving it's us
but you know relativity right
actually it doesn't matter the sort of
who you measure alright so the idea of a
Radian is to say that's changed in
perspective from this guy and how much
his hand has to turn to follow the move
on let's make this angle
let's make its measurement dependent on
how far this person goes around okay so
if we've got a arm a circle so if I if I
continued out the circle I circle the
radius one when that mover has gone the
same distance is the radius so if we
call this arc length one unit so I'm the
move-up right the reason why I'm calling
it one unit is because the angle right
will be the same no matter how large the
circle is okay so this could be 50
kilometers and 50 kilometers or you know
30 light-years and 30 light-years when
we move one unit we call that you know
because it's one-to-one it's a ratio of
one to one we call that one Radian okay
you guys are smart if you think about
what happens what from the observers
point of view okay
if the move-up went in a circular motion
all the way around from one side and you
have to turn exactly around you know do
a half a revolution right so there
behind you how far is this motion in
terms of the radius this radius here
right it's one unit
okay how far is that is that distance
what's the ratio between your radius and
that circumference hmm classmates about
area rights on the right track right
it'll be maybe pi times whatever your
radius is well they're right because
half the circumference right so in this
case it'll be PI right that's how far
they've got around PI units pi times
further than the radius okay
so that's why we call this angle that
corresponds to that movement right we
call it PI radians okay because that's
how far the person has moved with
respect to the reeds and of course if
they went all the way around it'll be
two pi radians because they've gone
twice as far okay just a quick note as a
side issue now I will always write PI
and I write the units as rad notice
because I like radians but because the
symbol for radians looks like that looks
like a letter C it kind of looks like
half of the degree symbol but it's so
easy to mistake for a degree symbol that
I just leave it off and I'd rather write
something that's kind of dangerous okay
so that's why I write so let's go back a
second come back over here okay this is
why if we're going from the perspective
of the move are we define one Radian
Alice do you remember what the
definition from one Radian is 1 Radian
ears okay it's the size of the angle or
the magnitude of the angle or that's
just the angle that no Mathis is you
this weird orchid word I don't know why
they use it because no one uses it in
English and they're perfectly good
synonym for it they use the word
subtended I prefer the the word formed
or made even
one Radian is the angle of this sport by
an arc right that are equal to the
radius of the circle so even though I
don't have a full circle here I'm
implying one because that arc there can
only go through a single circle right
there's no other circles that okay now I
think for memory this works out to be if
you're trying to translate back to your
old old system okay I think it's like
fifty seven point three degrees or
something like that which is more than
45 which is why I need your mind a bit
small okay but that's about how if I
have to go to make the radius equal to
how far you've moved okay so now that we
have this idea of measurement that's
where all of the other formula for
measuring circular quantities comes from
okay so let's think about now if we said
here one Radian is one radius around the
circumference right that means that the
length of the arc it's just your radius
in this case it was one times how far
you traveled around the edge as an angle
which is just one ring you write
anything this is it okay it was two
radians I would have gone twice as far
so you see how this makes it much easier
because we're thinking about the
perspective of the move on to work out
distances right like this right set up
with okay what at the area of a sector
well if we have the area of this thing
the area of a circle the whole thing is
PI R squared yes
but I know that that's the whole circle
what's the angle that makes off the
whole circle how far do I have to go
around
it's super high right so another way you
could write this is up off times that's
your body aa square right because two pi
is going all the way around okay now if
I don't want to go all the way around if
I just want to go say feet up around
maybe it's just one Radian or two
radians away look I will take not 2 pi
which is the whole circle right but just
whatever angle you got what are you -
Radian pi radians and then I'm still
multiplying by a square so of course we
don't usually write it like this we
usually put their feet up on the earth
okay all right now if you wanted to know
because I don't know why you wanted it
but if you wanted to know what this
party is right what shake we call that
boy that's a segment if you want to know
the segment you start with the sector
right and then I'm going to subtract
something so the sector is this part R
squared theta
what do I have to subtract I have to
take off this triangle yeah now there's
lots of different ways to express the
area of a triangle but based on what we
know I'll know the radius of the circle
and I'll know the angle because already
amazing right so when you know sides and
an angle right we said the area of a
triangle is 1/2 babies might see that
any bells
yes in this case a and B are both the
radius right there the sides around the
included angle okay
so they'll be half ah ah and of course
to see the included angle is the radians
that we've been talking about
if that's the feel right until signvideo
okay and of course that's why you can
take out a factor and here's what you
get now by the way can you see this is
why this formula or early works in
radians not in degrees is always
Parliament support if the difference is
just units surely I can use whatever
units I like right it's not like the
area of a circle it's like this really
works in centimeters doesn't work in
meters sorry guys okay why why because
this number here this theta right is
about a distance moved around okay if
you change you two degrees at least this
part you're talking about this guy
turning his hand around which is a
completely different measurement right
I want the length around the
circumference not a guy spinnings head
or sale of funneling the stops okay so
alright and that's all of your Radian
measure performance in a nutshell and
where they come from
okay